well I want to know about the signatures  all over you so I find a sharpie and  green room behind the stage backstage  the green room if you bow and and we  were just chatting with some colleagues  and friends and stuff and they're all  quite famous so I asked them if say my  shirt and I thought maybe we did auction  it or something I made some money for  charity like oh that's amazing but then  I kind of see who else do you love  people all the time you know you're  gonna action strategies that work where  you reach front which know sometimes I  don't quite know what we're gonna do  with it let's resolve the coffin and  alcohol field so and you know what best  dress then tonight  [Applause]  [Music]